[Music]
godzilla vs kong is nearly here and a
whole lot of man-made property is just
waiting to be smashed
exploded toppled set on fire or all of
the above at once
the world is waiting with bated breath
to see which giant creature emerges on
top once the dust clears or whether they
end up hugging it out and joining forces
against a larger threat
the monster movie to end all monster
movies drops in theaters and on hbo max
on march 31st
and if you have a place in your heart
for king size action you probably have
the date circled in red ink on your
calendar but will it be worth the wait
the plot of godzilla vs kong isn't
completely unknown
for one we already know why kong's
become godzilla's size since his much
smaller appearance in kong skull island
kong's the last of his kind but he's
still growing and you better hope he
does
because he we say once kong goes then a
big one comes up
reports from a godzilla vs kong set
visit and the movie's internet breaking
trailer have indicated that the face-off
between the two titans might very well
feature another threat that's more
mechanical in nature
mecha godzilla the legendary robotic
kaiju that's yet to make its monster
verse debut however whether the movie is
actually any good has remained a mystery
until now though you still have to wait
a while until the official reviews drop
the veil of secrecy is lifted enough
that the lucky few who have been able to
see the movie in advance are now allowed
to tweet their first impressions
it looks like fans of king kong and
godzilla can sleep easy because the
critic's early impressions indicate that
godzilla vs kong is everything you could
have ever wanted
and then some sean o'connell the
managing director of cinema blend
tweeted some extremely positive things
about the movie while also revealing
that some of the action takes place on a
hollow earth setting he wrote i had a
total blast with this movie
it gets wonky and weird and all of the
places a monster movie like this should
some of the human characters actually
work but it's the fights in hollow earth
that demand
a massive screen team kong shiraz
farouki of comic book debate confirmed
that the movie very much delivers on its
premise
and teased out audiences are in for some
seriously amazing action between the two
monsters
he tweeted godzilla vs kong is fun
vibrant action-packed and energizing it
lives up to the heavyweight match it
advertised with amazing visual effects
and action sequences
this movie is selling a spectacle and
that's exactly what audiences will get
bandango's managing editor eric david
agreed with that sentiment and also
pointed out that while big monster
action is obviously the draw here the
human cast is also great and the story
aspects hold water he wrote i've seen
godzilla vs kong and it is grade a
awesome the monster brawls are badass
and beautiful huge fights all well
designed and super gnarly solid story
strong cast really good score a true
midnight monster movie and my favorite
of the four modern godzilla kong movies
of course godzilla vs kong is no citizen
kane and some critics have pointed out
that when you take out the awesome
monster action scenes the rest of the
movie can feel somewhat lacking
jermaine lucia of gizmodo and io9
tweeted godzilla vs kong has excellent
action and effects the story is crazy
ambitious and at times achieve some
unique sci-fi coolness
i'd watch it again for that stuff but
most of the human angles are so
overstuffed illogical and pointless it
constantly took me out of it
collider's vinnie makuso enjoyed the
movie to the point that he stated
i'm going to watch this movie every day
that's available on hbo max turning the
volume on my television up a little bit
every time
however he noted that things aren't
exactly stellar when the story focuses
on humans
saying the human parts are still
bafflingly bad but the parts where one
giant monster wallops the other giant
monster in the face are incredibly good
the same outlets perry nemeroff also
pointed out the human plotline problem
though she felt that the talented cast
helps the issue
she wrote still don't think they've
nailed how to incorporate human
characters but the top-notch ensemble
helps while some critics seem to find
the human-focused bits of the movie
underwhelming it certainly seems that
godzilla vs kong is happy to be what it
is
a big fun lovingly crafted movie about
the two most famous giant monsters out
there duking it out
you'll get the chance to see how well
the movie succeeds in its mission when
godzilla vs kong is released in theaters
and on hbo max on march 31st
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the monsterverse are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you